اجتماع في وزاره الداخليه لتامين احتفالات
الكنائس في راس السنه الميلاديه وانتشار
امني ملحوظ قوامه 270 الف شرطي
الاسعار والغلاء والهموم الاقتصاديه بصفه
عامه هي ما يسيطر على افكار المصريين ليله
راس السنه
الاسعار تتخفض شويه والدنيا تتضبط
والحل يرجع زي ما كان يعني في 2000 23 مش
هيبقى فيه فقراء ولا مساكين ثاني
ليه عشان كلهم هيموتوا من الكوع والكلام
الاسعار وخلو الاسعار والكلام ده في حي
شبرا القاهره تخصصت اسواق في بيع مستلزمات
الاحتفالات وهم لم يغيروا من عاداتهم هذا
العام وظهروا في افضل صوره ممكنه وعند
الحديث عن السنه الجديده يتحول الامر
تلقائيا تجاه الاقتصاد
عشان الشباب يشتغل
وان احنا نتمنى العام الجديد يا رب يكون
دخلته سعيده على الناس بتمنى ان كل حاجه
تبقى احسن ومصر تبقى افضل من كده من ناحيه
كل حاجه الاسعار والدنيا والمعيشه
والبطاله والدراسه والتعليم والصحه كل
حاجه
في ليل القاهره كالمعتاد في احتفالات راس
السنه العام الحفلات في الفنادق وفي اماكن
اخرى ايضا شبه محجوزه بالكامل
عدد كبير من النجوم سيقوم باحياء حفلات في
فنادق القاهره والتي لم تحتاجه لنشر
اعلانات كثيره نظرا لشده الاقبال التذكره
يتراوح ثمنها في احد الفنادق ما بين 200
40 دولار الى 400 دولار
ولكن خارج الفندق سيستمتع من يسير على
كوبري قصر النيل الشهير بحفل وعروض العاب
الناريه يتم تجهيزها لكي ترفها عن
المواطنين
الامر لا يختلف كثيرا على ممشى اهل مصر
احدث اضافات المقاصد السياحيه على صفحه
النهر الخالد فقد ازدان بالاضواء استعدادا
لاستقبال رواد الاحتفال
وبعيدا عن اجواء الحفلات هناك من سيترقب
وعود القاهره بطرح السلع الغذائيه باسعار
مخفضه كما وعد وزراء الحكومه المصريه بدا
من اول يناير فيما يعرف باسم معرض اهلا
رمضان الا انه هذا العام سيقام قبلها
بثلاثه اشهر تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره